even traces of diesel are enough to
pollute wide areas of soil or entire
bodies of water whether it leaks from a
tank or is swept out in floodwaters but
this wadding can help it soaks up the
fuel within seconds and the wadding
continues to float conveniently on the
surface even when it's saturated it
makes the diesel easy to mop up and
leaves little residue you shouldn't
necessarily drink this water right now
because there could still be traces left
in it but it could be recycled through a
water treatment plant for industrial use
without any problem the directs oil
wadding was actually created by chance
the Saxony based company normally
produces waxes and solvents for industry
but during the production process a
mistake caused the machinery to extrude
an unplanned substance a wax in the form
of wadding the developers quickly
realized that the unexpected material
had a very special fibrous structure it
has very impressive absorbent
characteristics and when it absorbs oil
the material clumps and it can be
handled very easily a kilo of it can
absorb roughly 6 and a half liters of
oil so I don't need much of it at all
the NGO one earth one ocean has tested
the new wadding in Nigeria oil often
leaks straight from badly maintained
pipelines into the soil there you put it
again the wadding has caught the eye of
multinational oil corporations
environmentalist Gunter Bonin also sees
a growing market for it in Germany it
offers economic advantages over
granulate oil absorbance
I can use it on a polluted surface say a
lake with an oil coating and then
afterwards retrieve it squeeze it out
and use it again that's why it's
ingenious because I can reuse it over
and over in countries like Nigeria we've
developed or converted special presses
that are able to wring out up to 300
litres of oil the companies wadding is
already regularly deployed in Germany
the country's Coast Guard uses it as do
fire brigades during flooding events
depending on where it's to be used the
wadding can be integrated into different
forms sometimes cushion-shaped absorbers
are most effective in other
circumstances tubes might be a better
choice this is it's extremely important
because when oil is floating down a
river you can't just dump the material
on it because then you have no more
control over it you have to approach
things in the light of the operational
requirement and make things like
barriers for instance out of floating
tubes or if the diesel tanker breaks
down on the road and fuel is leaking out
you might have to plug up drains or if
there's some spillage at a company a
cloth form might be best to wipe the oil
up quickly and effectively effectiveness
really makaan so an unintended
production mistake has turned into a big
boon for the environment door X now
exports its oil absorbent wadding to 14
countries in all among them Israel
Indonesia and the United States
you